dna is
what they call the molecule of life
it carries the genetic code of an
organism
and
we're interested in the structure
and the structure of dna is
a right-handed double helix
where each one of the strings that form
the helix is made of a sugar group and a
phosphate group alternating sugar
phosphate sugar phosphate sugar
phosphate and that's called the backbone
to each sugar phosphate group it's
attached a nitrogenous base just call it
a base
and the bases in the two backbones
pair a with t and c with g and they are
held together with hydrogen bonds for
each turn of the helix so this would be
a full turn of the helix
you will expect to have 10.5
base pairs per turn
in what we call bdna and it's important
to note that it is right-handed for
the dna that is in most organisms if we
put the dna of all the chromosomes in
the human genome together we have more
than three billion base pairs three
billion base pairs of dna measure
approximately two meters all that dna
fits in one very small cell that is 10
micrometers in diameter every cell in
your body has two meters of dna in it
and
you can imagine then what uh what an
important problem it is to package this
dna in such a way that is easily
accessible for all the cellular
transactions
and at the same time that it doesn't
overflow or put too much stress on the
cell because of the sheer amount of
genetic material in there so in my case
i like to
study the geometrical and topological
properties of dna so even though we are
able to
model dna in its in all its atomistic
detail so going atom by atom and looking
at forces and interactions we're not so
much interested in that we're interested
in looking at dna as either a ribbon
or just as a curve when we model dns a
curve we're talking about the curve
drawn by the axis of the double helix so
this dna molecule will be modeled as
just a verb that is properly embedded in
three-dimensional space so we can model
dna in the atomistic detail or we can
look at it from further away and model
it as a ribbon where each one of the
sugar phosphate backbones is one of the
boundaries of the ribbon so you will
have a boundary curve that is blue and a
boundary curve that is
red still the axis of the ribbon is this
pink curve
and the advantage of modeling it as a
ribbon is that then you can measure the
torsion of this dna molecule as it rides
in space and as it's packaged in an
organism if you just model dna so you go
further down in the level of resolution
and you model dna as a single curve that
does not self-intersect then we can
start asking questions about topological
entanglement and how much this curve
wraps around itself in the human genome
the chromosomes are linear pieces of dna
if we look at the chromosomes of
bacteria a bacterial cell will have a
single chromosome and that chromosome is
circular
so no ants to deal with and just one
circle of dna also very long that has to
be
packaged inside the cell are they like a
tangled mess or are they packed in like
neat coils would you describe these
things as messy or neat
well that that's a wonderful question so
it it depends think about the the human
dna this curve will wrap around proteins
called histones and form some sort of
bead necklace and then these bit
necklace and it will coil up on itself
so
it's a coil of a coil it's a coil of a
coil of a coil of a coil so if we look
here at the diameter of the native dna
so the diameter here is two nanometers
here the diameter is approximately 10
nanometers and then there's higher
levels of coiling until you get to the
representation that you saw in your high
school biology where the chromosomes are
very highly organized and very tightly
packed like that now if we look at the
cell cycle for a human cell the
chromosomes don't always look like that
the chromosomes look like that add
metaphase right before the cell is going
to separate into two cells but at the
first stage of the cell cycle so if we
consider
the cell cycle
as starting here
this is what we call the g naught g1
phase of the cell cycle or interphase
then there is the s phase where
replication takes place there is g2 and
the metaphase and right here we will
have cell division
if we focus at the interface dna is a
tangled mass but there must be some
organization in there
because if it was a completely random
tangled mess
then
you can imagine that the cell would not
function properly so there is some
organization but if we zoom in and look
at the cell at this stage of the cell
cycle we can see
the different chromosomes that look like
noodles but they occupy distinct
territories within the cell nucleus and
then you're looking here well the
question is is there organization here
is there interaction between chromosomes
are some chromosomes more likely to be
found on the periphery of the cell
nucleus are some chromosomes more likely
to be found
in toward the center of the cell nucleus
all those are important questions how
can a mathematician even begin to think
about this well we start
simplifying the problem we start looking
at dna as a curve so each one of these
chromosomes will now be just a curve no
sequence no helix no
no complexity other than this very long
curve embedded in a very small
environment
and then we can use polymer models we
can model this in the computer where the
curve instead of having a smooth
parametrization for each one of these
curves we turn these curves into
polygonal curves it will be just a bunch
of vertices and edges and these
polygonal curves can have these
different properties but you can imagine
that by doing this we have simplified
the problem dramatically now we just
have a sequence of vertices and their
coordinates in space and the knowledge
that vertex 1 connects to vertex 2
connects to vertex 3 etc when we have a
circular chromosome then vertex n will
connect back to 1 and we can put the
restriction that the edges be of same
length so that we have an equilateral
chain and we can put restrictions on the
chain and we can approximate the
behavior of a dna molecule using a
polygonal chain so if you have a circle
like this and then well it can be moving
in space just by thermal motion and we
are interested in finding all
conformations not just the circle that
could lay flat on the table does it coil
upon itself if so how many times does it
coil upon itself or this circle could be
knotted so the knot could look
nice and
and fat like that
but the knot could also be a very tight
knot
or
it could have some coiling about it
where if you looked at it you would not
recognize its identity but it's still
exactly the same knot so we want to
explore the space of possible
conformations
for a given topology be it an open
circle or a trifold knot like this one
and then apply that knowledge to the
models of packing now if we take a very
long chain and we allow
it to move in three-dimensional space we
can measure
geometrical properties like the rise
which measures the amount of coiling of
this curve around itself or we could
measure the radius of iteration which
intuitively is the radius of the
smallest sphere that contains this chain
if we
do that then we can apply that directly
to a chromosome and think well
what is the space that a chromosome
could occupy if it wasn't constrained if
it wasn't in three-dimensional space
well the chromosome would occupy
such space if it was in
three-dimensional space and then we
compare that to the space that it
occupies in the nucleus and that gives
us a measure of the amount of compaction
this chain is undergoing as it is
packaged inside the cell nucleus
topological entanglement so the cell has
an army of enzymes that the moment they
see a knot they'll come here they say oh
look there's a knot here okay we need to
break it they open they break they
transport